you know for more than half a century
we've simply known it as mccarran
our big airport it has grown a lot since
being named after the man who helped get
it built
former nevada u.s senator pat mccarron
but
there's been a long effort to get his
name off the complex and it may be
destined for success
later this morning are hector mejia live
at mccarran hector what are the
commissioners saying about
wanting to change the name
well they say that mccarran's views from
back in the 1930s just don't fit in with
today's
nevada so there's been a lot of talk
about this there you see the name right
across from us mccarran
international airport critics say
mccarran's views from the 1930s are
racist and anti-semitic
so remaining renaming mccarran
international airport one of the busiest
in the country is gaining traction again
the clark county commission is set to
vote on the name change later on this
morning
if it eventually gets approved mccarran
international airport would be renamed
in honor of former u.s senator
harry reid pat mccarran is the former
u.s senator who represented nevada back
in the 1930s but critics say
he has a history of racism the
congressional delegation even asked to
have his stature removed from the
capitol building at one point
county commissioner tick sega bloom is
behind the latest move to strip
mccarran's name from the airport
segregates to have enough support on the
commission this morning
to make this a reality when we come out
of this pandemic las vegas is going to
be
seen it's a new city a lot of people
around the world who've never been here
going to come here
everybody wants to come and the fact
that now we're going to have a new name
for our airport is kind of fits into
that hole
this is a new nevada a new day in
history
today's vote would really just get the
ball rolling the faa would have to sign
off on the plan
former governor brian sandoval who is
now unr
president along with unlv's president
keith whitfield
support the name change and rebranding
would likely cost 2 million dollars to
change all those signages
all the signs commissioner segerbloom
says that will likely come from the
pockets
of private donors reporting live this
morning hector mejia
8 news now